so the next talk is by eric play who is
going to
uh tell us about vc dimension
and sample-based testing
thanks in india uh the work i'll be
talking about is joint work with renato
ferreira pinto jr and nathan harms
and i just want to mention nathan harms
will be participating this week i think
he might even be here right now on zoom
so he'll be here and happy to answer any
questions you have
i'll also be happy to answer any
questions i have but
you might have but let's first talk
about our topic
i want to talk about kind of one of the
most basic questions that's driven a lot
of research on property testing which is
just this
very simple or general question which
classes of functions can we test more
efficiently than we can learn
and ideally much more efficiently
asymptotically or maybe polynomial
factors better
to make this question precise you need
to specify exactly which setting you
work in
and i want to ask maybe what should be
the most fundamental setting to study
this in at least
from the point of view of learning what
if we actually ask this question
in the model that corresponds to just
the pac learning model the original pac
learning model
and here there's something a little bit
surprising to me anyways which is that
despite all our research on this general
question for this specific model
we really have very very few results uh
at the very least before i started this
project
with renato and nathan if you told me
about any
of the classes that we typically study
in property testing or in learning
i would not have been able to tell you
if we could actually test it more
efficiently
then we can learn the same class or not
for essentially any class that we could
think of
so okay so let me actually make this
question precise
and introduce some of the notations
definitions we'll use
the pac learning model i mean i'm going
to just for simplicity talk about the
proper learning
framework and here there's two things
that are important there's a
distribution d
which is on the domain of some unknown
function f
and you get samples x1 x2 all the way to
xm from this distribution
and for each of those samples you
actually also get to see the label the
value of
f uh on this input and you don't know f
all you know is that it comes from some
class h of functions
and what you want to do is output a
function that's close to f so
distance at most epsilon from it where
here the key point is that this distance
is measured according to the unknown
distribution d
now what we're going to say is that m
learn of h is the minimum number of
samples required to learn
a function from this class and this is
kind of
how we'll be comparing testing and
learning in terms of sample complexity
so okay so this is the learning task and
now if we want to compare apples to
apples for the testing task we want the
model to be kind of the same where again
i get x1 through xm drawn from some
unknown distribution d
but now i'm not promised that the
function f actually comes from the class
h
indeed my task is to distinguish the
case where
f comes from this class from the case
where f is actually
far from every function in the class h
and now i again want to ask how many
samples do i need to do this i'm going
to write this as
m test of h
so what do we want to ask now we want to
ask how
or for which classes can m test of h be
much less than m learn of h i guess
implicitly i'm making this assumption
here that learning has to be at least as
hard as testing
this is a classic result of gold right
gold wasser and run
and it carries over to many different
settings for testing and learning it
carries over to this setting as well so
even in the standard pack learning model
or
the distribution free sample based
testing model
uh the algorithm the testing by learning
algorithm does apply and so it means
that
if we ignore the additive one over
epsilon term here
the sample complexity for learning can
never be smaller than the testing
complexity the samples that i need to
test the same class
and also actually even already in the
same paper there was
another an example shown that there are
classes where
this inequality can be very large there
can be a huge gap between testing and
learning
uh sample complexities and here this
example it's good to keep in mind
because it might show up again
later in this talk just take the class h
of all the functions that are completely
unrestricted
if the first bit is zero but always take
the value one if the first bit equals
one
and so here we can easily convince
ourselves it's very hard to learn these
functions but it's actually very easy to
test them even in this case when we only
get samples
and even if it's under an unknown
distribution if it's far from being in
the class it won't take many samples
before we actually get evidence that the
function is not in the class so we can
test it
with a very small number of samples
okay but now as i mentioned if you
actually asked me about
other natural classes of functions i
didn't know uh until very recently
of any examples that i could give you
that are natural where
there is a big gap between testing and
learning
uh in our work that's on the archive
right now you can see that
actually there are two very basic
classes where we can show a large
separation a quadratic separation
between the two juntas and monotone
functions
but actually what i really want to talk
about today is the other direction
it turns out there are many other
classes that are natural
for which you can't actually hope for
this kind of separation
so specifically there are many natural
classes of functions like half spaces or
intersections of half spaces ptfs
decision trees of small sizes and quite
a few other ones
where the separation between the two is
going to be at most the log
factor uh this is the lower round i
actually want to talk about
and what i actually want to talk about
to kind of give you an idea of the proof
and the main idea that i want to
introduce about this uh
i'll be talking about half spaces
so before i rush through with the proof
of half spaces this is a good point to
ask if there's any questions in general
so in all these classes is the learning
complexity something which is
i guess dependent on the ambient
dimension right so the testing
i guess i just wanted to ask like is the
log factor hiding just a
factor dependent on epsilon or is it
more than that
uh it's going to be a log factor in uh
the learning sample complexity itself so
not just in epsilon but
in the learning sample complexity we'll
actually see it it turns out this log
factor will be familiar especially given
the talk that we just saw about
distribution testing
okay let me explain this a little bit
better
uh what i mean by this answer so here
just to have some notation i'll write
ltf for the class of half space
functions
when you're in n dimensions uh so
r to the n uh i think all the results
with a slightly different argument they
all hold if you're looking at boolean
functions as well so half spaces over
the boolean hypercube
all the results will carry on over we
just need to change the proof a little
bit
but okay so what do i want to prove i
want to prove that the testing
the number of samples i need to test is
roughly the same as the number of
samples i need to learn half spaces
uh how do we do this well the first part
is easy if we're only asking about
sample complexity for learning
and i'm not worried about runtime which
i'm not for this talk
then actually it's only a question of
computing the vc dimension of the set of
half spaces
so half of this theorem of determining
the number of samples i need to learn
half spaces
is kind of this classic well-known
well-understood task
in learning theory
so we're left with the other half of the
task we need to determine the number of
samples we need to actually test
this same class and
the real main message i want to get
across today is actually it turns out
there's something very similar to vc
dimension that we can use to also
compute this sample complexity
so not only the learning sample
complexity but also the testing sample
complexity can be determined using
vc-like
dimensions
so okay so vc dimension the standard
definition here just to introduce again
uh the notation i'll be using h
i'll use to represent my class of
functions or the property i'm testing
uh the domain will always be represented
by
x here and i'm only looking at boolean
functions
and now the key concept here the key
combinatorial concept
is shattering where we say a set of
points from the domain
x is shattered by h if there is a
function in
h that takes all possible sets of labels
on those points
and the vc dimension is just the maximum
size
of any set that can be shattered by age
and now this fundamental theorem of
learning says that once you know the vc
dimension you also
know the learning sample complexity at
least in the setting where i'm thinking
of it where i think of epsilon as a
constant
then it really completely determines the
number of samples that you will need
okay so now i'm promising you that we
can do something similar with testing
uh and what i want to do is actually
take two slight variants
of vc dimension the first one is to say
instead of just looking at all possible
sets
to compute the vc dimension of h i can
do the same thing
restricting my search to any subset of
the domain
so for any subset s of x i can say the
vc dimension of
h with respect to s is defined exactly
as before it's just the size of the
maximum set that can be shattered by h
just under this restriction that i'm
only looking at subsets of
s and so this has been defined before
but usually if you care about learning
you you won't really look at this notion
because you can only increase in
by taking s to be the entire set x and
so that's
most often what's being done but for us
it's actually going to matter that we
like
looking at vc dimension with respect to
a subset of the domain
and once we have this i only want one
more definition
which i don't think has a name in the
literature so we're going to call it
lower vc dimension just because it
always takes a lower value it's bounded
above by the vc dimension
and what i want to do is i want to take
the exact same definition of vc
dimension
but i want to replace the there exist
symbol with for all
so what does this mean i'm going to say
the lvc dimension
with respect to a set it's just the
maximum cardinality k
where every set of size k or at most k
is shattered by h so instead of just
asking for the maximum size
of a set that's shattered i want to say
the maximum cardinality i can get
that guarantees that all the sets are
shattered by age
so this is vc dimension and this is lvc
dimension
and i just want to mention a few basic
observation
about those two measures uh essentially
as an excuse to give you a bit of time
to ask more questions about this if
anything is not clear
but what can we say i just mentioned lvc
is always bounded above by vc for any
subset and this is just
by definition itself
but we also know that the two dimensions
really are different from each other in
the sense that this does not always
have to be a very tight inequality there
are classes of functions for which
the lvc dimension is much much smaller
than the vc dimension
and we can come back to the exact same
example when we separated testing sample
complexity to learning
to see an example where actually lvc is
a constant maybe one whereas the vc
dimension is going to be
extremely large maybe as large as the
size of the set depending
uh so we do have examples where there's
a large separation we do know that one
is bounded above by the other
and we also know that there's actually
quite a few natural classes
where the two are the same so there are
some cases where the two measures are
very different and there are
other cases where the two measures are
exactly the same
and in fact for half spaces this is the
case as long as you give me a set of
points in general position
the vc dimension and the lvc dimensions
will agree
and this is by the same argument that's
actually used
in standard textbooks for half spaces
for just computing the bbc dimension the
same argument
actually gives you that the vc dimension
is the same as the lbc dimension
okay but
why does this help us uh what i'm going
to claim now
is that actually just knowing that the
vc dimension is the same as the lvc
dimension for
a large enough subset s is enough to
give me a really strong lower bound
on the testing sample complexity for
half spaces
and specifically i can state this lemma
more generally to say for any class
if you have vc dimension being the same
as lvc dimension
then the sample complexity uh will be
up to log factor exactly this lvc
dimension which is
here by this condition the same as the
vc dimensions so
all of those classes will have testing
sample complexity at most a log factor
better than the
sample complexity for learning the same
class
how do we actually prove this uh the
proof
will fit in this one slide the idea is
going to be that we just pick a random
function
and we're going to choose some
distributions d over s and we're going
to be a little bit more careful how we
pick our distributions
now the intuition being that if i pick a
random function
it should be far from the class h
but this is actually not necessarily
true this will really depend on my
choice of the distribution d
and if i look at this a little bit more
carefully i'll see that actually
if d is a distribution that has a
support
of size much less than the lower vc
dimension
then actually what this means is that it
has to be consistent
with some function in my class
so the function f even though it was a
random function if you only look at it
at a very small subset
it completely agrees with some function
that's in the class
and on the other hand if you do take d
to have large support size
um to have a lot of mass on much more
than end
points then actually yes now our
intuition is confirmed by the standard
source
or cyros lemma that says as long as
i have many more points than my vc
dimension the probability that i happen
to be
close to some function in my class is
going to be extremely small
so what does this mean this means that
actually if i have a tester for
h in this distribution free sample base
model
i can estimate the support size of a
distribution
and estimating the support size of a
distribution is actually this very well
studied
nice problem in distribution testing
where we know that you need n over login
samples
and so this actually is the sketch of
the entire proof for why the moment you
have
lvc being the same as vc dimension
testing is at least
essentially as hard as learning the
class
any questions about this so far
okay so now what i'm saying is we can
put the pieces together
and we get our lower bound between them
by just
using the vc dimension for learning the
main lemma for the lower bound
and we get our result
uh what's nice is we can apply this
technique to many more classes so there
was
we saw that half spaces satisfied the
condition that we needed for this
lemma to apply and it turns out there
are many other classes
where we have this condition that the vc
dimension is equal to the lbc dimension
so this actually ties into
some of the many structural properties
of functions that have been studied in
learning theory so in particular maximum
classes
always must satisfy this property
and there's another class of functions
analytic dudley classes
also must all be maximum so they all
satisfy this equality
so there's a few examples here of
other properties that we can use or that
we can
prove lower bounds for using this same
technique
uh i think there's a question so
as you ask whether n over log n is tight
do we know if log n is the best number
we can get here
that is a fantastic question that's
going to be one of my last questions at
the end
we don't know uh and i'd be really
interested to find out i think it would
be really nice if we could find out
whether this login is necessary
what i can say is it isn't necessary for
this lemma
so the lemma itself or the more general
version of the lemma at least we do know
that the login
factor must be lost for some properties
so there is a tight upper bound in
general but i'll come back to this at
the end that's a really good question
i have a more basic question what's the
maximum class
uh i was hoping to skip over this to
have everybody who's seen maximum
classes just not and say okay cool
the the short version is this shower
source
lemma tells us how much the class can
grow as
you go over the vc dimension size for
the samples
a maximum class is going to be a class
where the inequality in this lemma is
tight so it's the one that grows
exactly as the lemma satisfies uh
which to me always sounds like a very
odd condition in the sense that
it's not clear to me why this should
give some really nice structural
properties but it does which is why
they've been studied quite a bit
uh i also want to raise one more
question though like what happens when
you don't have this nice property
what happens if you're actually looking
at a different class of function where
you don't have the equality
and it turns out actually the real main
limit that we prove in the paper
is much more general it does apply even
when your
lower vc dimension is not exactly equal
to the pc dimension
and what we get then is the bound that's
actually stated here in this lemma so
that
uh the bound will be non-trivial but
uh only when the lower vc dimension is
somewhat comparable to the vc dimension
in the extreme cases
then actually the lower bound is not
meaningful
as you would expect actually because of
the example that we saw where testing
can be done
with a query complexity that's really
independent of the vc dimension
uh so i mentioned it can be applied for
more properties this way
uh just one more thing i wanted to just
mention quickly
it actually this kind of lemma applies
for other problems that don't
fit the general framework that i've been
talking about so far of pac learning
functions
it works for testing clusterability and
it works for testing lp feasibility
in the sense that it was introduced by
epstein and silvwell
earlier this year and for cluster
ability i can even state the result just
a little bit more precisely here
let you look at it here we don't have a
function we just have a distribution of
points and we want to know if there's at
most k
centers where each all the points are
close to one of the centers
uh say unit distance uh at most from one
of the
centers and so it's a nice result of
elon dar parnas and ron
that you can test whether a distribution
of points
is k clusterable or whether it's far
from k clusterable
uh with a number of samples that's only
n
roughly n times k ignoring the log
factor
uh and using our main lemma and the same
kind of proof technique we can actually
show that
this is essentially type again up to
these log factors
and that's it those are all the things i
wanted to talk about
i just wanted to leave you with kind of
three questions
uh what i skipped over this is uh
how you actually prove lower balance for
the lvc dimensions for the classes where
it's not equal to the vc dimension or
even showing that it's equal to the vc
dimension
this is where there's a lot of specific
arguments
for different classes but what's nice
about this is that
they're nice combinatorial arguments so
you can look at these
classes of functions have these
combinatorial arguments that give you
these results for
testing sample complexity so the obvious
question is kind of to see
for which other property this could hold
to see where else even lvc dimension
could be used but i wanted to kind of
raise three other
questions that are not this obvious
follow-up question
and the first one is kind of related to
the question that was asked before like
is the login factor necessary or not uh
i think that would be really interesting
to understand when it's necessary
and when it's not if it's always
necessary if you always need
like if you have a matching upper bound
of n over log n
all the time uh or if not so if
you do have a matching upper bound for
example for our half spaces
this shows us that actually testing is
easier than learning by just the log n
factor but still
it would be easier and on the other side
if you show that actually no
we can improve the lower bound to order
n
i think this would be equally nice
because it would show that actually the
support size estimation problem that's
kind of
hidden inside all these testing problems
is not the only bottleneck so it's a
question of
is this the only bottleneck or is there
something else that could stop the query
from a sample complexity from being
lower
there's a second again i guess kind of
obvious but
really interesting direction that uh
we haven't had time to look at yet so
it's completely open
is what we kind of showed is that if you
look at vc dimension
it can be used for giving you the sample
complexity of testing problems as well
as long as you use some variants
of vc dimension with it and you could
ask the same question about all these
other notions of dimensions or
complexities that have been used in
learning
do any or do do any of those dimensions
also have analogs that work
for understanding testing better
and the last question i want to leave
you with is a much more
uh restricted question i don't think it
has any
uh deeper connections to
the work that i've presented here today
but it was one of those
annoyances that i'm hoping someone here
in this workshop can resolve for me
um what is the vc dimension of decision
trees
as far as i know the best known bounds
are omega k but order k log n for size k
decision trees
uh and as far as i know there has been
no improvements on
this in the last 20 plus years uh but
i'd be very happy to learn that i'm
actually wrong here that i
just don't know about some results
that's it
thank you very much oh thank you eric
so we have a couple of more questions so
first is
uh arnob is asking can you explain
more than how you extend to functions on
the hyper
cube um
everything i've said kind of uh
applies as is until i get to the
just to the point for example here
where i'm talking about points in
general position we just need a slightly
different argument
to argue about vc and lvc dimension for
half spaces
here with the hypercube i guess i
i forget exactly what we did for half
spaces but
in all the cases i kind of want to claim
conceptually it's very similar
for the hypercube as for the real space
so
that's my half answer maybe my better
answer is nathan will be happy to tell
you a lot more about it
throughout this week so i've actually
promoted nathan
nathan you have panels now so you also
wanted to add a comment so
maybe you can do that uh
actually did i do that successfully did
i uh nathan you can unmute yourself and
uh hello yeah hi sorry yeah i just
wanted to revisit uh uh
joe neiman's question from earlier about
uh
the upper bounds that i uh so you asked
if there's if the log n is necessary and
so in in general yes it's necessary
because there's an order n over log n
upper bound for
testing symmetric properties
which matches yeah it matches our lower
bound
could i ask a question about the lemma
um i think it was slide 13 the one with
the
uh the sketch of the annover login
lower bound for the test for the testing
sample complexity yeah
yeah i think i'm i think i'm i have a
bad intuition here or something that
like
what what about distributions i mean the
same issues arise for estimating support
size but what if the distribution d is
like
has only a very very tiny amount of mass
on these
yes uh yes
so here i am skipping over those details
you're right so
what we actually want to do if i'm being
a little bit more careful how i'm
writing things
is we want to identify these
distributions d
that have mass at least one over n or
proportional to one over n on each
element in its support
and then we want to choose the support
to be either fairly small or quite large
so there are additional
structural properties that we need on d
for this to actually
be correct i see okay that totally makes
sense thanks eric
do we have any other questions
i mean the next stock is 15 minutes from
now so plenty of time
okay uh so if not then well
uh thank you eric and the next talk is
by rocco
uh the video in 15 minutes so uh
two two weeks do we go do we like okay i
guess
we're not going to switch up the
recording but uh
actually do we just like take away